and that confessional you admitted one  of your fears  what was it there's a little part of me  that wants to see Kim get dunked because  I don't think she will be honest because  they are just not keeping it 100 with  each other talk to him  we have a section and I don't know if we  can be intimate together I haven't had  sex what is your fear with Wynn are you  sexually attracted to me know what Lynn  said that just made me feel terrible I  don't see a future with wind right now  now when you also had a confession about  your sex life yeah I really feel you're  not attracted to me when I kiss you  really kiss you a touch you I don't feel  any reaction back so what does that mean  for the future of your relationship you  can't or they have a relationship so  that's probably where we stand right now  this is so intense this is way intense  [Music]